keep in mind that for responsive images
like adaptive layout that we learned
about in the last few lessons
we frequently will want to adapt the
size of the image the layout size of the
image depending on how much space we
have sometimes we do that with simple
scaling for example here on our
conference app we're currently rescaling
the speaker images depending on the
layout size
sometimes though we may actually want to
switch between subjectively different
images too
for example you might want to crop your
subject more closely when you don't have
as much space to render the image
using images differently in terms of art
direction in different scenarios is part
of what makes these responsive images
rather than just scalable pixel ratio
images